les progrès les plus significatifs
depuis le début de la guerre le ministre
turc des affaires étrangères affiche sa
satisfaction après un nouveau round de
négociations à istanbul pour le heat la
priorité est de parvenir à un cessez le
feu
cette guerre qui a entraîné la mort de
milliers de personnes et le déplacement
de millions d'autres à doit cesser
maintenant au cours de la session
d'aujourd'hui nous avons vu que nous
avons parcouru un long chemin à cet
égard
à la sortie la partie ukrainienne
annonce qu'elle pourrait accepter un
futur statut neutre pour cela elle
demande un accord international pour
garantir sa sécurité et avance des noms
de pays qui pourraient être garant de
cet accord en échange l'ukraine
accepterait qu'aucune base militaire
étrangère ne soit installé sur son
territoire et n'intègrent ray aucune
alliance militaro-politique des avancées
certes mais hors de question pour le
président ukrainien de baisser la garde
- nous pouvons dire que les signaux que
nous entendons des négociations sont
positifs mais ces signes on ne couvre
pas les explosions d'obus russe c'est
pourquoi nous n'allons pas nous calmer
nous n'allons pas diminuer nos efforts
de défense à la fois dans le nord de
notre état et dans toutes les régions
d'ukraine où les troupes russes sont
entrés
de son côté la russie a annoncé une
désescalade partiel sur certains fronts
en ukraine
le ministère de la défense de la
fédération de russie a décidé de réduire
radicalement l'activité militaire en
direction de kiev et de tchernihiv pour
accroître la confiance mutuelle et créer
les conditions nécessaires pour
poursuivre les négociations
la france aussi tentent de peser sur ces
négociations
emmanuel macron s'est entretenu par
téléphone avec vladimir poutine ce mardi
soir